I went viral because a magician made me
think I was invisible and this is that
story okay so this all started about a
year ago my girlfriend told me about
this small acting gig that was looking
for people to be extras on the Netflix
show but I was getting off work early so
I thought what the hell we got the
instructions to meet at this location I
was like like way in North Hollywood
like it kind of seemed kind of sketchy
so I was like okay I mean long as they
got food right it turns out they were
filming this show on hypnosis we were
just gonna be audience members but they
needed volunteers me being me I
volunteered I kind of felt like they
needed an idiot but it had to be for
like the right kind of idiot I love
myself I know I'm not an idiot but I
mean if I need to be an idiot I'll be an
idiot if I have to okay so they had us
do 20 tasks while under hypnosis like
being a ballerina or like picking up an
extremely heavy banana best thing I know
show's over I mean I got paid call it a
night let's sleep so a few days later I
get a call asking me if I was available
to come to another set to film on the
actual Netflix show but I thought oh
okay
turns out the hypnosis was the actual
audition why wouldn't I go to this I
mean this could be huge for my career so
the day comes I show up I get prepped
for the shooting okay so now here is
where the story takes off I was told to
be a part of a magic show I mean not
hypnosis what a magic show when my head
I'm like oh snap I love magic I mean who
doesn't like magic so when I get miked
up all that struck me to do was you know
have a natural reaction and just be
natural looking back I should have known
something with them like I should have
known something had of you but it just
seemed too good to be true you know I
get told to you know walking the scene
and sit down
the magician asked what was here and you
know obviously yeah
I'm the guy so I'll volunteer he calls
me in another volunteer to these chairs
and we both sit down so I'm thinking you
know he's gonna be something I mean I
like magic but I mean I don't believe in
magic I mean come on now I'm 28 years
old next thing I know he puts the quilt
over the the other volunteers head and
just snatches it off and this dude was
gone
Mike he was gone I don't go believe it
man there's like I mean at this point
everything that I believe in everything
I believe in my faith it can't be
explained like this dude is gone
suddenly the magician turns me in ass
you ready
oh no I'm not ready you know say like
bro like explain this man what is this
sorcery I'm completely terrified at this
point I'd literally just saw somebody
completely vanished in front of my eyes
the blanket goes over my head I'm just
like I'm breathing out hard and
everything I'm just I'm going eight at
this point so the blanket comes off
everybody screams everybody goes like
numb and I'm a thousand percent at this
point sure then like I was invisible
okay so what really tipped the scales
was when they had show me the picture
that they had taken beforehand I mean I
know what you're thinking like this is
the available challenge but it hadn't
been made at that time because it was
the first time it was happening to me
dude you see all those those clips of
people freaking out that's because it
really really messes with your head I
mean if you saw the Netflix episode and
obviously you can see that I had some
fun and you know that I was you know
going around messing with people I mean
who wouldn't do that I mean you're
invisible okay so I sit back down in the
chair and I was made visible by the
magician again you know I go home
you know same process you know take a
shave shower you know same old hey I'm
just literally trying to process what
happened like I can't believe it like
I'm dumbfounded boom fast 40 year whole
year goes by you know I'm chilling at
home you know my girl like you know she
gets the text message from her friend
saying that he really likes this magic
show on Netflix and I'm like I think I'm
in now I think that's what I mean so now
everybody's asking me all these
questions about show blah blah blah I'm
literally trying to convince people that
my reaction was real like everything
that happened was organic I post the
video on my Facebook you know sharing it
with family and friends like just by
kind of celebrating the fact that I
actually made it on Netflix like you
know mama I made it yeah I'm saying few
days later it just gets lit at this
point like it gets five times crazy I
see myself turning on like
you to worldstar Instagram Twitter
Twitter blew me up man shut up we're
talking hundreds of millions of views on
all social media platforms combined so
you know how people walking up to me you
know asking for autographs you know
asking for pictures
I can't even work in peace but I got
people coming up to me at work saying
you're that guy you're that guy I'm like
yes I mean I am that guy obviously the
trend just blew up like it turned into a
challenge people were just all over the
world like tagging me because they were
making their kids go invisible and it
was just the oh I got it was just so
crazy like my kids man they were just
crying it's all the people who freaked
out in those videos I've been there so a
few days later during all the madness I
got a phone call
it was the magician it was the magician
he caught my haven't spoke to this guy
like a year they're like I'm gonna fall
like you know you know I'm all excited
and everything he's telling me like yeah
we made so many people smile and like
while we're on the phone like I tell
them like I am and it just feels so
great I'm really waiting on Ellen to
call through that hey man I want to get
on Ellen bro like I don't wanna be on
stage man I just want to be in the crowd
like you know yep that was me he's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah like that's exactly
that's exactly
unfortunately he ended up getting the
call and he went no Ellen without me I
do understand this because I mean he is
the magician at the end of the day you
know the video was featured on Ellen you
know I mean so that was that was already
huge yeah
count your blessings that brings us to
today I had four thousand followers on
Instagram now I have eleven thousand
I'll take that people all over the world
you know contacted me it was really
really big a whole class took a class
picture and then sent it to me holding
up the gang gang sign that you know that
they thought they thought that I created
I mean I had gifts just gifts
I had gifts I mean how many people can
say that they went viral in a lifetime
and have a challenge after them I mean
that's blessed I don't know what you
call that but that's blessed so yeah
[Music]